the crew is an MMORPG or at least that's
what the games creative director Julian
Garrity says it is I recently spent some
time playing the game and while I'm not
convinced that the designation of MMORPG
applies here I was surprised by the way
in which elements we might typically
associate with RPGs are being
incorporated into this open-world racing
game similar to loot in action RPGs each
piece of equipment has a level and a
color-coded indication of its quality
slotting in better gear improves your
car's performance
I started out driving a Mustang and
found the car felt heftier and less
responsive than I would have liked but
whether this is a reflection of the
games driving model or just a matter of
tuning and customization I don't get no
my time with the crew started in Detroit
and before leaving Michigan I took part
in the take down mission with my fellow
players we were cooperating to do enough
damage to an AI controlled vehicle to
disable it and also competing with each
other to be the one who did the most
damage and therefore reaped the biggest
rewards in terms of money parts and
experience points this was an off-road
mission that took me over the rolling
dunes along the shore of one of
Michigan's Great Lakes which felt about
a million miles from the industrial
streets of Detroit I later drove from
New York to Miami which took maybe 10 or
12 minutes this left me feeling like the
highways that connect the game cities
are meant to give you the sense of
traveling from one place to another
without actually making you wait too
long to reach your destination there's a
story here that's meant to give the game
structure and provide you with an excuse
for progressing from one region of the
country to the next here taking some
cues from The Fast and the Furious films
it has you going undercover to
infiltrate and undermine a gang that
dominates the illegal street racing
scene the world of the crew is filled
with cooperative and competitive
missions and skill tests but in my time
with the game it was the prospect of
just hitting the open road and cruising
around that appealed to me the most I
was kept on a tight leash while playing
so I didn't have the chance to indulge
my wanderlust but I'm already excited at
the thought of seeing where the roads of
the crew can take me
it's a big big world if you want to join
my crew look for me on the highways of
America there's a good chance I'll be
cruising somewhere in the Midwest with
the top down and the radio on when the
crew comes out for PC PlayStation 4 and
Xbox one this fall
you